>> ALL WEEK WE'VE BEEN TELLING
YOU ABOUT THE JOY REED YOU NEVER
KNEW, THE MSNBC ANCHOR ONCE HAD
VERY DIFFERENT VIEWS, NEWLY
REVEALED FROM EXCERPTS FROM HER
NOW DEFUNCT BLOG, FOR INSTANCE,
SAYING IMMIGRANTS WERE TAKING
AMERICAN JOBS, DESCRIBING OUR
FRIEND LOU DOBBS AS HER
IDEOLOGICAL TWIN ON IMMIGRATION,
AND TOLD DEMOCRATS TO SPEND LESS
TIME ATTACKING WHITE PEOPLE
AMAZING, AND ALSO COMPARED JOHN
McCAIN TO THE VIRGINIA TECH
SHOOTER, SPREADING 9/11
CONSPIRACY THEORIES.
IN APRIL SHE COMMENTED ON THOSE
BLOG POSTS.
>> I SPENT A LOT OF TIME TRYING
TO MAKE SENSE OF THESE POSTS.
I HIRED CYBER SECURITY EXPERTS
TO SEE IF SOMEBODY MANIPULATED
MY WORDS OR FORMER BLOG, AND
THEY HAVE NOT BEEN ABLE TO PROVE
IT.
HERE'S WHAT I KNOW, I GENUINELY
DO NOT BELIEVE I WROTE THOSE
HATEFUL THINGS.
>> WELL, WE ASSUMED THAT REED
WOULD ONCE AGAIN CONTINUE TO
BLAME THESE NEW SET OF OPINIONS
ON A MYSTERIOUS FAKE HACKER,
BECAUSE HE'S DONE IT BEFORE,
BUT, NO, THIS TIME SHE ADMITTED
THE TRUTH AND SAID SHE'S SORRY.
GOOD FOR HER.
IT'S BETTER NOT TO LIE SO MUCH.
THERE'S AT LEAST ONE OUTSTANDING
QUESTION HERE, A QUESTION THAT
HANGS IN THE AIR.
WHATEVER HAPPENED TO THAT FBI
INVESTIGATION THAT JOY REED AND
MSNBC NEWS ORDERED UP WHEN THEY
WERE STILL PRETENDING THE BLOG
POSTS WEREN'T REAL AND MAYBE
COMMITTED BY VLADIMIR PUTIN?
IS THAT INVESTIGATION STILL
GOING?
HOW MUCH DID IT COST?
IS NBC GOING TO PAY BACK
TAXPAYERS?
LARRY, THIS IS A REAL QUESTION.
BY THE WAY, AGAIN, I JUST WANT
TO SAY, GOOD FOR JOY REED FOR
TELLING THE TRUTH.
IT'S ALWAYS GOOD TO TELL THE
TRUTH.
>> A LITTLE LATE.
>> THEY DID ORDER UP THIS FBI
INVESTIGATION, AND NBC STOOD
BEHIND IT.
ARE YOU ALLOWED TO DO THAT IN
PERPETUATION OF A HOAX, WHICH IS
WHAT THEY DID?
>> LAST I CHECKED, NOT SO MUCH.
I CHECKED WITH A COUPLE OF
FORMER DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE
OFFICIALS, AND THEY SAID THAT'S
A CRIME, MAKING A KNOWING FALSE
REPORT TO THE FBI, AND THEN NO
ONE KNOWS HOW MUCH OF OUR
GOVERNMENT RESOURCES HAVE BEEN
SPENT ON INVESTIGATING A HOAX.
NOW THAT THE FBI ISN'T SPENDING
SO MUCH TIME INVESTIGATING
POLITICAL OPPONENTS OF BARACK
OBAMA, ONE THINKS THEY ACTUALLY
WOULD LIKE TO CHASE DOWN SERIOUS
CRIMES AND NOT JUST JOY REED'S
FANTASIES TO COVER HER OWN BUTT,
BY THE WAY.
LET'S BE CLEAR HERE.
HER LIES, WHICH WERE REINFORCED
BY HER NETWORK, NBC, THEY WERE
JUST TO COVER HER UP, MAKE HER
LOOK GOOD, IT WAS JUST TO
PROTECT HER JOB.
APPARENTLY SHE DIDN'T HAVE TO,
BECAUSE NBC WILL STAND BY HER NO
MATTER WHAT.
>> YEAH.
BY THE WAY, I'M ALL FOR NETWORK
STANDING BY THEIR ANCHORS, I
SHOULD JUST SAY, AND I ALSO
THINK THAT MOST PEOPLE ARE
DECENT AND FORGIVING.
I THINK IF YOU SAY, I'M SORRY I
SAID THAT, MY VIEWS HAVE
CHANGED, MOST PEOPLE THINK
THAT'S OKAY.
I CERTAINLY THINK THAT'S OKAY.
WHAT'S NOT OKAY IS TO WASTE OUR
TIME, THE RESOURCES OF FEDERAL
LAW ENFORCEMENT PERPETUATING A
LIE.
A LOT OF PEOPLE DO THAT, BY THE
WAY, AND NEVER PROSECUTED.
SHE WON'T BE PROSECUTED.
BUT SHOULDN'T NBC HAVE TO REPAY
THAT MONEY?
WHY DO THEY GET A PASS ON THIS?
>> I WOULD THINK SO.
LISTEN, I UNDERSTAND, I'M ALL
FOR RADIO NETWORKS FORGIVING
THEIR EMPLOYEES, WHILE WE'RE AT
IT, LET'S HAVE THAT ON THE
RECORD, BUT I DO THINK NBC HAS
TO ANSWER FOR A COUPLE OF THINGS
HERE.
THEY WERE PART OF THIS, TUCKER,
CIRCULATED THIS REPORT FROM JOY
REID'S CYBER SECURITY EXPERT
THAT SAID SHE HAD BEEN HACKED.
THAT DAMAGES THEIR BRAND,
BECAUSE THEY'RE IN THE BUSINESS
OF FACT-CHECKING EVERYBODY, AND
IT'S TIME FOR THEM TO SAY THIS
WAS BOGUS, IT WAS WRONG.
THERE NEEDS TO BE TRANSPARENCY
THERE.
WHATEVER THIS ENDED UP COSTING
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT, NBC,
COMCAST, UNIVERSAL, THEY SHOULD
REPAY THAT MONEY.
>> WELL, I MEAN, THEY'RE LIARS.
WE KNOW THEY'RE LIARS.
THEY LEAKED THE "ACCESS
HOLLYWOOD" TYPE TO "THE
WASHINGTON POST," THEY DID IT
FOR POLITICAL REASONS, AND NEVER
ADMITTED THAT.
>> THEY WERE GOING TO DO A
THOROUGH INVESTIGATION INTO
THAT, TUCKER.
I REMEMBER THAT.
>> YES.
>> THEY MADE A LOT OF NOISE
ABOUT THAT MORE